alright it looks like we are now live on
the AMA for July 2000 in and I'll be
taking questions in just a moment I'm
just finishing up doing a little work
with getting things linked to here and
there so while everybody is is rolling
in and starting to write their questions
and answer questions that it's not
questions and answers I'm going to quick
give a thanks to all of my patreon
supporters for making these AMA sessions
possible take a you know a good bit of
time out of the day I'll try to answer
all the questions that I get let me give
a quick thanks to all of my patreon
supporters and it's kind of nice here
today here in Milwaukee anybody who
wants the link wants to become a patreon
supporter get cool perks and stuff like
that you can easily do so yeah so right
now it's it's a kind of overcast and it
was hot haha this week got into the 90s
and I think in some places up to a
hundred that's a 100 Fahrenheit of
course not Celsius for any of my
non-american listeners and viewers so
here's some questions already shooting
in here little yell 69 starting with a
big question what made me study
philosophy and it's not a question that
you can answer sort of all at once
because there wasn't any like one moment
or thing that made me get into studying
philosophy and then studying philosophy
has taken on different meanings over
time for me as I have sort of you know
changed and deepened my my approach I
think you know at the beginning it was
mostly being interested in asking bigger
questions and thing
in larger scope and then being told that
hey that's what they do over in
philosophy and I did I mentioned this
story many times I had a philosophy
class when I was in high school that was
actually quite terrible and then I had a
religion class it was actually a
philosophy class that was actually quite
quite excellent and then I you know when
in the army read some philosophy while I
was in there you know it bought a few
books came out worked in a restaurant
for a while and then started going back
to college and declared a major right
away so mark Seymour what do you think
of the barrel so the barrel for those
who don't know is a Facebook group that
I was invited to and they engage in a
lot of memes and [ __ ] posting and that's
basically what they're doing it's
interesting but mostly people far
younger than I am and some of the posts
are you know very interesting and and
have cool common threads on them some of
them I you know when I look at them and
I see that a post is basically just kind
of a waste of time the night I don't pay
attention to it much as you know the
same thing in in the stoicism forums
that I often contribute to as well but
you know it's a it's cool that we have
all these online communities I mean
think back to what it was like when I
was a young man and we you know we did
have some internet connectivity but it
was all dial-up modems and BBS's and now
we have so much you know inter
connectivity with everybody else all
over the world is very very cool
nabil in Islamic philosophy all gazali
announced the death of philosophers or
anyone in Western philosophy like that
yeah there's tons of people I mean even
just in the last century in both
analytic philosophy and continental
philosophy we had the end of metaphysics
and there's even a great article called
the end of the end of metaphysics which
is about John Luke Mario of course you
know many movements and analytic
philosophy have announced you know the
the end of philosophy as we know it
so there's there's plenty of people
doing that and I imagine there's gonna
be lots of people doing that for
centuries to come but it it's
interesting philosophy never does die
out the way that they they seem to
demand that it does all right uh Baraka
Joe son what are my favorite works of
fiction well you know if I was really
really pressed and I had to say what is
my favorite work of fiction I'm guessing
it would probably be something by philip
k dick you know a man in the high castle
is a pretty brilliant novel and there's
there's some others that can arrival to
like you know three stigmata of Palmer
Eldridge i waver i go back
full-width from from time to time on
that I also know huge fan of Dostoevsky
you know and my favorite work by him is
not The Brothers Karamazov off the way
everybody feels a blob 'la gated to say
you know no it's the one that's called
the possessor the demons which is which
is another great work what else was
really really like drawing me in I mean
I think that's probably it for right now
but you know I went through like a
Graham Greene phase and an iris Murdock
phase and I there's there's quite a few
works of fiction that I really enjoy and
some of them are classic things you know
I I do enjoy rereading the Odyssey I had
to teach it recently into a tutorial
client and it was fun to go back over it
all right oh here's an interesting one
unit on any quick advice to give to
someone who is about to give their first
lecture yeah so without becoming
obsessive about it pay attention to how
you're speaking to the audience because
there's a tendency for first-time
lecturer or readers to read and speak
very fast and also in a way that's a bit
monotonic and remember that you're you
may be reading something that's
available as a paper like you know at a
conference or maybe you're just giving a
public lecture the audience can only
follow you if you leave some pauses and
if you don't speak at them too fast I
know there's there's a tendency
especially if you really love your topic
to want to talk pretty fast but you get
as much stuff in there as you can't be
people can only process so much so every
once in a while maybe it takes take a
pause and that will help you out and
again you don't want to be obsessive
about it you don't want that to turn
into the one thing that you're thinking
about all the time but that's probably
one of the things that I've seen
happened the most the other bit of
advice I'll give is
if you screw up just you know don't let
it get to you and start from where you
screwed up and the audience will
generally be a-okay with you going back
over it it's not a musical performance
you're working in the world of thought
so you know and they're there to hear
what you have to say cyrix what's your
legacy what would you like to be
remembered as that's a good question so
my legacy is kind of all over the map I
mean it's really only a legacy after you
die so hopefully it won't be a legacy
for for a long time or after you retire
I don't plan to ever retire I'll
probably die doing doing what it is that
I do well is it well I suppose that the
YouTube videos are probably a big part
of it you know I've done quite a bit of
academic writing but nowhere near what I
imagined I would have gotten done by
this time so I don't know that that's
really that that big of a legacy
certainly not what I was shooting for
and you know there's there's all sorts
of other things you know I've helped a
lot of people by making connections or
introductions or giving people advice
and you know I've had enough time I mean
I already started happening when I was a
young professor but I had enough time
seeing the fruits of that to think that
that that you know there's every one of
us can have a kind of hidden legacy of
people we've influenced and and helped
out that we may not even know about or
are never gonna actually on anybody
else's radar and I think that's you know
that's more important in some respects
you know what would I like to leave is
my legacy I'd like to do a lot more
writing and have that stuff out there I
keep on you know I'm planning on
shooting
videos I'm gesturing at the chalkboard
behind me I plan on shooting videos
until you know videos quit being a
medium or or I get too old and sick to
do that or you know if people just say
hey you need to hang it up you're
getting senile thinking like that I'm
gonna try to turn a light on here see
it's really quite dark so let me there
we go that's a bit better one of my
studio lights Francis a longtime
commentator on the videos and
participant in these my old mentor his
brother had their father tell them to go
to university even when the brother was
a successful entrepreneur mmm what is
the true intellectual personal value of
education I guess that really depends on
you know what you're studying and who
you're studying it with and what
attitude you're bringing to it and you
know we're where you are sort of in your
life and progression there is something
to be said for studying for the sake of
studying learning for the sake of
learning rather than without any attempt
to read any instrumental value
if you know in the humanities are the
classics because people have found them
valuable both for applying things and
understanding in all the situations that
we're in but also for their own sake
generation after generation after
generation I mean there's also the like
you know we created a cannon so we have
to stick to it but that's not that's not
really enough to keep that going so I
think that's that's part of it as well
DM on pure Ava hi dr. zedler you're a
legend I was wondering whether you
believe in God or not and and why well
this is something I've talked about
quite quite a bit here and there yeah I
believe in God and I you know I grew up
Catholic left the church came back I'm
now kind of a fairly when it comes to
practice lukewarm and not very
consistent person but I don't have any
issues with belief and you know it's
it's one of those those sorts of things
where you know I I think in part because
I've read so much within the ancients
and the medievals in the early modern
zand
and seeing other people take interesting
thoughts seriously helps with that I
mean the real question that's that I
think one ought to ask is now do you
believe in God because how that could
mean anything you know can be some some
guy who thinks of God is like the
bearded guy in the sky who shoots
lightning bolts when you're naughty or
something like that or could be some
deus watchmaker's God or it could be all
sorts of things the the real question
that that people want to consider as
well what's what's how do they conceive
of God and how do they think they they
get at any sort of understanding of the
divine let's look at some more here it
just kind of jumped a bit so I think a
lot of people have written stuff
philosophy and science what do you think
of communism and slavo Dziedzic what
communism is an equivocal term it means
a lot of different things you might have
in mind
actual communist states of the present
like say North Korea or the thing that
you know is kind of communist and
Khayyam kind of not the People's
Republic of China which i think is
actually much more similar to its old
imperial states at this point when you
have a party congress where the party
actually decides that workers are not
that important debatable how communist
you really are and then there's you know
communism understood as a philosophy and
there's a lot of varieties of that it's
not just whipping out marks there's
there's been a lot of different going
off I think that that Marx was right
about quite a few things but I I don't
take any any one philosopher as the
Prophet who's got everything right
Dziedzic you know he's an interesting
guy he demands a lot of time and effort
to really get at everything that he's
doing in his works and quite frankly I
don't have that time available to me so
I read you know I've read his stuff in
the past I don't spend much time on it
now but I do enjoy when he comes out
with op-ed pieces and I know where he's
coming from
on that gray and Maru fee how can I
learn about modal logic is there a good
introductory book I I don't know if
there's a good introductory book there's
all sorts of introductory books for
moral law for modal logic out there that
you can check out and I would just you
know go to the library and dig around
you know all the presentations of modal
logic that I'm aware of do so in a very
straightforward axiomatic way you do of
course need to know the basics of the
predicate calculus in order to be able
to understand modal logic but you know
it's it's it's fairly straightforward
stuff I think Daruma what do you think
of jordan peterson asked and he answered
many many times already so I'm not gonna
go over that again juan Rodriguez which
of a manual const books would be the
best to start with now that's a great
question
yakhont is somebody who like aristotle
there's no easy introductory book to get
into right I mean with like Epictetus
you can say okay read the enchiridion
with Plato well maybe we'll have you
read the Meno or the ion or the apology
you know so Kant does have two books
that are more or less like introductions
to the the speculative or theoretical
philosophy the range of pure reason and
the practical philosophy the the realm
of practical reason and those are the
prolegomena to any future metaphysics
and the groundwork to the metaphysics of
morals and these are the books that I
think most generally we introduced
taught to learners through the other
thing you could read Hackett actually
has a nice little addition with like
essays like perpetual p/es and and what
is enlightenment and stuff like that in
it and those are those are a good
introduction to Kant
- but you're not going to get so much of
his philosophy through that the biggest
problem with Conte
I think is it's almost like the stuff
he's writing is put into a sort of code
that needs to be explained to you you
know you read terms and you're like
what's this analytic synthetic thing
that he's talking about or he'll use a
word like experience or desire and he
doesn't always mean the same thing that
that that you mean by it in ordinary
life so it's it's very important to sort
of learn how to crack that that code and
once you do then a lot of it falls into
place and then some of it you're like he
can't possibly mean that can ii and the
answer is yes he doesn't think that like
when Khan thinks that happiness has
really nothing to do with ethics or at
least your happiness he is he is serious
about that so yeah I mean generally the
the groundwork or the the prolegomena
I will mention that when I have the time
which will probably not be until next
year I do want to shoot a series of core
concept videos on the prolegomena I've
got plenty on the groundwork of
metaphysics of morals and I will be
bringing out online classes on both of
them in my teachable Academy so you can
look for those
all right Mohammad Nietzsche talked
about the higher man in his fourth book
in the spoke zarathustra who is he I
don't mean the ubermensch I don't know
I'd have to go back to that I'm kind of
hazy about that reference there's you
know we don't just have one single like
Superman or great man or somebody who
can free themselves from the shackles of
culture and and nihilism and all that
there's there's a variety of types
within Nietzsche so to 0 for 6 thanks
for your videos and lectures I enjoyed
your series on Plato and Aristotle you
talked a lot about the virtues in
happiness what is Aristotle's meta decks
what is the grounding of the virtues
meta ethics I'm gonna say this sort of
like once and for all is pretty much
[ __ ] that's a distinction that
analytic philosophers love to make and
it doesn't really hold up under scrutiny
you know when you actually think things
through every substantive ethics has a
meta ethics it has a view on what ethics
is about and how you know moral
judgments arise and critic you know
criticisms of its other rival theories
and likewise every meta ethics is a
substantive ethics emotivism is a great
example so if you're trying to approach
things in a very axiomatic sort of like
well here's a little meta ethics and
then here's the substantive ethics a
very artificial way you're not going to
understand Aristotle what is the
grounding of the virtues he gives you a
bunch of different discussions of that
some of it has to do with the function
of human being some of it has to do with
our orientation towards happiness
some of it has to do with the very
nature of what a virtue is but
that's there in Nicomachean ethics so I
think you can easily find that ah here's
a good question that is not about
philosophy at all
and I would have to think about this one
what is my favorite food if you ask me
when I was a kid you would have had an
immediate answer spaghetti spaghetti
with meatballs and I still really do
love spaghetti with meatballs and I I
make my own you know sauce and meatballs
I don't make spaghetti although my my
wife has a pasta maker and she she wants
to start making our own pasta I mean
another thing that I really do like is a
good hot sour soup you know I got kind
of spoiled I'll tell you a little bit of
a digression story so when I was an
undergraduate I got hired as a tutor to
to do these two Chinese students from
Taiwan in American history and then
fairly quickly there's like a little you
know circle of Chinese students one guy
from mainland China a lot of Taiwanese
and a few people from Hong Kong and they
they found out that I could tutor very
well and I was good at helping them sort
of edit papers to remove the kind of you
know grammar issues and and syntax
issues that come up when Chinese
students are writing in English and so
pretty soon I was tutoring like all
sorts of people in this this small
Chinese community and and the school was
only paying me for like 10 to 20 hours a
week so they would help me out by making
me food you know and also giving me
cigarettes cuz I smoked all the time you
know and we'd smoke a lot as we were
doing these study sessions and so the
first time I actually encountered hot
sour soup it was not at a Chinese
restaurant it was you know like cooked
on the stove at home and man it was good
and and you know there's good hot sauce
soup and then there's like kind of just
phoning it in hats
you know there's different variations it
can be made in different ways I like it
kind of peppery you know with the dog
ear mushrooms not only people subbing in
other mushrooms but that's that's
another real comfort food for me all
right
Rocco I would like to hear my take on
focus on how to cultivate it what was my
approach to studying when I was getting
my degree well that I don't have much to
offer
you know I back then I had very good
focus I have somewhat less of it now in
part because I have too many things
going on but a lot of it as a matter of
like when you find your mind wandering
from the task you bring it back you know
it's a lot it's sort of using the will
to condition the will and so I don't
have a hell of a lot to offer on that
awful philosophy I'm looking into
phenomenology to become obsessed with
how to do a phenomenological description
you have any resources or texts you'd
recommend is a how to write thanks you
know James Edie has an introduction to
phenomenology book that again haven't
looked at it for a long long time but I
remember as being quite good and a lot
of people found it useful for learning
how to write phenomenological
descriptions and I think it's also
important to like look at the
descriptions that classical
phenomenologist provided maybe not
Husserl's because those are really
boring for the most part but other
people's descriptions like you know
merleau-ponty is kind of fun to read you
know leve nos and you know use them as
kind of models I think if I remember
right there is like some sort of
repository out there on the Internet of
phenomenological descriptions and I
don't remember which group it was
associated with but I think there's some
stuff out there
Pedro what do I think of Nietzschean
thought and strictness of thinking and
morality
well Nietzsche is one of those thinkers
you know there's like about 30 different
Nietzsche's out there depending on who's
interpreting him right
so Nietzschean thought I like Nietzsche
as a thinker I think he's very
interesting I think sometimes he's on
point and in his criticisms of other
people and sometimes he's way off way
off track but I like you know working
through him he's always fun strictness
of thinking and morality I think there
are ways in which you know we can get
into cul-de-sacs so to speak with being
very rigorous and the thinking we're
rigorous in the ways that we're applying
our thought and and morality and
sometimes they really are rooted into
you know more more less less rational
and more emotionally based things or
just part of our culture right so nature
can be useful that way I'm not sure
about Nagre cornier Leo's question what
did you treat at your PhD so I can't
really say the answer Mohan sir you're
gonna have more classes about Hana
Arendt I don't have any classes about
Hana rent I did a lecture about her
that's not a class will I have more
lectures about Arendt yeah will I ever
have classes about Arendt I'm a it
depends on how much I can get done so
you know my answer very often to anybody
who's asking about the you want to see
this or you want to see that are you
supporting on patreon because that I
don't you know I do teach occasionally
as an adjunct that's not providing my
main income my main income is provided
by the services that I do in terms of
tutoring speaking all of that sort of
stuff
patreon is there to help me actually get
other stuff done on the side so if you
want to see me doing more of the free
stuff
that's that's how to get me to do it
right everybody has to earn a living
Salvatori I remember you having watched
some anime with your son do you remember
any of the titles with any by any chance
yeah we watched Dragon Ball Z and I
don't remember any any other stuff but
he's really big on that and that's great
but you know he doesn't like when I ask
a lot of questions about the people or
what the hell's going on
you know more than I understand because
I didn't like that one when I was a kid
and people that asked me about you know
these pictures on the D&D books or
things like that or you know the heavy
metal bands that I was listening to but
yeah I mean I anime is not something I'm
gonna put a lot of time or thought into
quite frankly TK what do you think makes
a good person in which philosophical
works do you feel represent those values
best so you know I'm a virtue ethicist I
think that the the traditional virtues
are important
those include you know key ones that we
often call cardinal virtues like justice
you know courage or fortitude temperance
I think Aristotle was on the right track
and talking about you know the virtues
concerned with honor and wealth is
something different I think that anger
probably should be treated as its own
separate thing the way Aristotle did
rather than sort of pushed into
temperance or pushed into courage or
anything like that and I think that you
know honesty is a very important one in
our own time there's a lot of people who
are honest in one sense but also a
complete jerks and in another sense it's
you know if you if you want to say I'm
just being honest with people you really
have to like you have a duty to like
think through whether you've got it
right the terrible thing that you're
telling them about about stuff and I
think that's part of what goes into it I
also think that you know this is
something that doesn't get emphasized
enough with virtue ethics until recently
we need to think about the fabric of our
relationships with others and how they
function as a sounding board or check-in
point for us you know we need friends
who can say hey man you're screwing up
you're acting like a dick you need to
fix this that that sort of thing I think
everybody needs that even even the
proverbial sage why are they sages
because they surround themselves with
the right people to help them do that
sort of thing
so which philosophical works represent
those values best well you know I mean
you can't really go wrong with starting
with I've mentioned this in a number of
places Plato's Republic Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics
Epictetus is discourses those are three
great works they don't encompass
everything you need but they set a good
agenda for you that you can then fill in
with with other things boss ask them is
sort of impossible to answer question
did Hegel agree with Kant's critique of
Pure Reason wait you mean like with the
whole book or with some sort of outline
of it or with what Kant project was or I
mean and what do we mean by a grue
rehear Hegel obviously is is doing
something different and it's not just
merely teaching Kant's oh yeah there's
gonna be some places where he's
disagreeing with can't I think he viewed
Katz work as you know an important
advance but rather formal and is sort of
raising problems that it didn't resolve
but what does it mean to agree with an
entire work I I don't know does that
mean agreeing with every single
proposition in it or agreeing with where
it winds up or you know that's that's
something to think about Muhammad is
there any philosophy and artificial
intelligence yeah there's plenty of it
and the whole idea of artificial
intelligence doesn't just come out of
Comp Sci people a comes out as
reflecting at it you know and and much
of what those those guys are doing at
high levels just as with any field
became philosophy I mean think about
Alan Turing and the Turing test is the
Turing test merely something in cops eye
or is it a bit of philosophy there yeah
there's tons of stuff
my gray what are your agreements and
disagreements with marks well I mean
that would be quite a long thing I think
that you know to begin with his whole
historical determinism thing I think is
wrong right and I think that marks well
there's a critique you know many other
people make as well I think about mock
Schaller and his arguments with Marx I
think that Marx is is good in picking
out how economic developments and and
dynamics drive things within other areas
and are often overlooked but he's he's
wrong to try to reduce everything to the
economic sphere and so our you know
traditional Marxists in that respect I
also think that one of my favorite works
by Marx is actually the 18th broom the
era of Napoleon
no 18th Lumiere of now I'm gonna have to
look it up I'm getting it mixed up and
it's about how if you read that work
it's it's the one where he says like you
know there's the whole tragedy farce
thing but it's it's really about how
social breakdown occurs and how elements
of what we might call us or
proto-fascist regime can come in and
take advantage of class distinctions and
the parties that go along with that and
exploit it and eventually install a
military dictatorship quite a good work
well we're thinking about so all right
correct answer is what is the difference
between reason and intellect if there is
any depends on whose version of reason
and intellect you're working with that
is a distinction that does get made in
the Middle Ages for example between they
call it ROTC oh and intellectus some
thinkers like like an some and you won't
find this in the treatises you'll find
this in the memorials of st. Anselm
because this is either the dikteon saw
me or the day sitting alternative boost
says they're the same thing right
somebody also comes
Aquinas or many other people in there or
to think about Boethius before that
right we'll differentiate and
intellectus is higher than ROTC oh so
intellect and understanding or intellect
is higher than than reason reason is
discursive intellectus is non-discursive
in German idealism it's the opposite in
that case you know for Kant first and
understanding intellect is lower and
fitter Nuland reason is higher and you
see that again in Hegel and you see that
in the English followers of transit you
know transcendental philosophy like
Coleridge so it really depends on whose
scheme you're you're adopting alright
and and each one has got different ways
of articulating it so you've got to look
at what they have to say well it will um
what are the problems in whose roles
conception of the transcendental ego I
have no idea at this point cuz I don't I
don't really spend much time on oral or
critique about him
so I don't know what uh I would I would
say about that at this point I just lost
things cuz it scrolled down a bit Oh sir
X what is the ideal world philosophical
or not in your opinion meaning not what
is possible but what would be ideal if
it could be then why could it not be
well it would be a world in which
everybody's needs are met everybody is
able to develop and is respected and
their humanity can fully flourish why
could it not be I mean look around there
are their prospects for that for most
people not so much
it's kind of a mess but we're not in
much more of a mess than than we have
been in the past
you know Olson why did you choose
philosophy are you happy with your
choice there's no one single thing that
made me choose philosophy am I happy
with my choice yeah but I understand
philosophy and a broad enough way that
it ties in with history and literature
and it has something to do with my life
if I was a typical very narrowly
specialized academic philosopher maybe
not so much
dr. Nancy Moss is here is your god
believe close to Spinoza's are different
what's nothing like Spinoza's I mean
very few people are like Spinoza he
comes up to it you know but there's this
great line about Hegel right that if
Hegel was a Christian he was in a church
of one meaning he was the only guy who
saw things exactly the way that he did
and there's so there's more people who
think Spinoza's way but not a hell of a
lot of them so rancid logic philosophy
channel never gonna do a video on John
macelli a the medieval French Catholic
priest who's really an atheist probably
not I mean unless you commissioned me to
do it because I've got a lot of other
stuff that needs to be done you know
there's there's so many gaps in the
videos that I've got available I mean
think about it this way I just brought
up Spinoza and I do Spinoza way before I
would work on on some some figure like
that unless I guess again somebody
Commission's me if you really really
want to see a video on X then you can
hire me to create those videos it's sort
of like the you know the thing about the
hobby horse you can ride your hobby
horse all you like on the Kings Highway
but you got to pay the tolls wha how
should one read specifically how do you
read do you take notes as you read or
after both and how do you retain all
this learned information well I'm not a
good model because I have never been
somebody who had a lot of trouble
retaining information and I'm kind of
slipshod and note-taking often times
when I write notes I don't go back to
them you know when I was like prepping
from my preliminary examinations I did a
lot more note-taking but in general you
know I I read what I'm reading and if I
decide I wanted
notes I'll usually write it in the book
or if I'm you know using a Kindle or PDF
I just use a highlight function but my
way is not a way that's going to work
for most people I think Oh son who's
your favorite philosopher I do not have
a favorite philosopher I have a number
of favorite philosophers and they you
know they kind of fit into pantheon you
could say Marilyn Cronenberg where can I
find the best explanation of the gada
merhaba Mas debate no idea that's
something that I imagine you'd want to
write to God Amuro ha Burma scholars and
maybe they could give you an answer on
enlightenment philosophers like Hume
Locke Berkeley and Pascal well if you if
you've been following me on patreon or
in you know YouTube or things like that
you know that I actually am shooting
videos on Pascal and those should be
coming out fairly soon now that I've got
those those Play Doh videos out of the
way and yeah I'll be shooting videos on
other thinkers I mean you've got a lot
of empiricists and they're he and walk
in Berkeley and you know I'll do that
when I when I can again if you want to
see content that that you're really into
getting placed up front you you feel
free to write me at Grega treason I own
we'll talk about a commission who is
this what are some of the walls you've
found in the study of the philosophy of
language mostly disciplinary stuff right
where people don't read each other's
work and they saw they're reinventing
wheels or they're saying this can't be
done even though this this person over
here already did it that's probably some
of the biggest stuff
why isn't consul lectures on ethics a
good intro to his thoughts the essays in
it are actually quite fun to read and
don't presuppose familiarity with his
writings well that works for you then
that works for you I've already answered
the question so you know there's your
your
thing nagaru cornelio what advice do you
give for someone who wants to make a PhD
in philosophy shot a whole video about
that easily Google I meant here PhD in
philosophy aka wasted time time
unemployable garbage that's just a dumb
comment think because obviously some of
us are employed kind of weird to get on
somebody's AMA and then you know tear
down the degree that they have but
that's Daniel do you think there could
be an analytic reading of Hegel does the
fact that many Hegel's terms notion
spirit negation shift and develop from a
dialectical reason from being analyzed
there are analytic readings of Hegel
Brandon is is a good example of that of
course though when you read Brandon you
realize that he actually starts to
become very different than than most
analytic philosophers in that he
actually knows the field quite well and
he references Hegel's predecessors like
that you could ask the same question can
there really be an analytic Thomism you
know an analytic treatment of Thomas
Aquinas as works that root that's really
faithful to the movement of his lot
analytic nietzsche i'm very dubious of
these in part because I've seen these
projects and usually they're they're not
very good but you know there's there's
people doing it so that's that's what
they do are Devon thanks for the videos
they help a lot glad that they they they
do help you
so that's that's really nice and that's
why I have them out there it looks like
Neil was all over the place
- I can smack at different people on
here so I am going to what I'm going to
timeout
all right let's see here nog lovey can
any of the Stoics help me deal with a
lack of it yeah she can pick him up and
fan yourself right that's a silly answer
but uh yeah I mean you can you can think
of it as physical hardship I mean I'll
tell you a story when so when I was in
graduate school I lived for about four
or five of the years in my graduate
school existence in a trailer that was
older than me in a trailer park and the
air-conditioner worked but the trailer
was was so you know old and rickety and
and the windows weren't good I never
turned the air conditioner on this was
in southern Illinois where we would have
day after day of a hundred degree
weather super humid and I would just set
up one fan at one end of it and another
fan at the other end it was so hot in
there that my cats would pant like dogs
and they would go hide in the bathroom
and that's that's the environment in
which I was studying for my preliminary
examinations and writing my course
papers and and reading and then in the
winter I kept because you know again it
wasn't very well insulated
I kept the trailer at a cool 55 degrees
you know that's when I set the
thermostat and you know I made it it
didn't kill me and it actually probably
toughened me up quite a bit as a matter
of fact the only time I actually had air
conditioning and used it was when I
lived with other people who couldn't do
without it and when I have the
opportunity not to have the air on and
just just be in the natural environment
I usually do that so yeah that's uh
that's a good question for you I mean
you could think of it in terms of
voluntary endurance of hardship and
trying to use it to make your
stronger all right
let's look down subconscious qualms are
there any fascist philosophers whose
works are worth reading depends on what
you want to read them for I mean and
this also applies to sort of
proto-fascist like Cheryl Marah you know
if you want to understand what fascism
was about and what people were thinking
at the time and how how it could become
attractive then yeah you want to read
them or have you see them as a present
danger yeah you probably should read
them are there any who are worth reading
in the same sense that like reading
Cicero is worth it or reading Aristotle
is worth it nobody comes to mind for me
but you know that's that's that's me all
right here's one totally out of
philosophy boogie reverie five all-time
favorite records in no particular order
and it's a good question so they're all
gonna be metal for me of course Iron
Maiden's peace of mind
Judas Priest sin after sin Motorhead's
another perfect day
tanks honor and blood and rats out of
the cellar
Jeremiah sir can Viktor Frankl be
considered a philosopher good question
yeah he definitely can be considered a
philosopher and I mean you know he's
also at the same time a psychotherapist
also a psychologist but those you know
we often like to there's a broader point
we often like to say a person's like
this or their that they're there they're
either a philosopher or make sense out
of this because of the the grammar so
I'm gonna skip that that one Garrett
what does Kierkegaard mean by
dialectical the more I read the more I
feel like there's different meanings of
dialectical he uses that's a good point
I think that's right I think that
dialectical does have different senses
so I'm gonna I'll say a few things right
so the in the immediate background of
course is Hagel and
just Hegel but the but there's also
another sense of dialectical that
Kierkegaard is incredibly aware of
because Kierkegaard isn't just a guy
who's responding to the philosophy of
his time he is somebody who knows Plato
and Aristotle and a lot of classic
philosophy inside and out
he wrote his dissertation on Socrates so
Socrates put forth you know an
understanding of dialectic that Plato
picks up on and that's that's something
lurking in the background Aristotle also
spends a good bit of time particularly
in the topics a little bit in some other
works like the metaphysics and the
rhetoric talking about dialectic and
what it does as well so those are all
kind of lurking in the background and I
think you're right that he he's probably
got more than one sense going on Ricardo
Flores what are your thoughts on Trump
well I didn't vote for him I think he's
an embarrassment you know I think that
the Republican Party is really digging
itself into a hole by going in all in
all in on supporting him and on
supporting other sort of things in in
their own orbit and yeah I mean the
stuff that that he routinely says in the
fact that he thinks that it's okay to
say it is pretty awful things have
gotten really bad and bad on on a lot of
different sides if I want to imitate him
right many sides there's a lot of blame
to be thrown around that we have this
guy in charge and his like ever-shifting
cast of yes-men characters in the
background as well I don't I don't have
any proposals for who ought to replace
him but yeah he's definitely a sign of
the times
the body politic is very sick here in
the United States Robert Royston if you
have time would you say qualifying some
hypotheses as impossible even after
having strong current empirical data
against them might be something
irrational take the noter of future time
travel for example humans have the
tendency to consider present information
proven hypotheses is absolute this has
been proven to be wrong I I don't really
understand the question very well or the
example how it fits in their qualifying
some hypotheses is impossible that's not
qualifying that's sort of categorically
saying something all right
qualifying is when you say well if this
then that will happen I mean could could
could deciding that some hypotheses are
impossible to be something irrational
yeah I mean sure that's always been the
case so and and it even if you like you
had you could you could qualify or you
know say something to be something and
have good reasons to do that or you can
just do it because you feel that way or
or you know that's what your current
cultural system says or something like
that so 2046 do you think virtue ethics
leads to a sort of virtue politics or
some degree of statecraft and Soulcraft
is at work or the current ago that the
correct polish shouldn't some degree
concern itself with virtue ideally yeah
I mean didn't even back in Aristotle's
time Aristotle few Rita's politics says
and he's a guy who actually did with his
in effect graduate students surveys
empirical studies of all the available
Greek police up until that time he says
none of them are well ruled none of them
have a good Constitution some have worse
some have better and so yeah it can lead
to a sort of virtue politics that's why
when people ask me well you know are you
democrat or republican I'm not either
I'm an independent always so you're a
centrist nope I'm too traditional to be
a conservative what passes as a
conservative these days because there's
certain values that I think we need to
recognize that have dropped out of the
picture for the people who should be
conserving them and I'm far too radical
to be a liberal you know because because
they eventually
but they don't converge just in sort of
a base horseshoe theory if you're
concerned with virtue then you're gonna
be very unhappy with with many of the
political processes of the time and
you're gonna try to make them better
when you can but also realize that
you're dealing with for the most part
people who are not motivated by that as
their value so all right let me scroll
down a bit I can't read the Chinese
characters so I'm not even gonna try to
is there any philosophy that can help me
deal with knowledge that one day the
earth everything on it will be destroyed
by the Sun leaving no trace that it ever
existed I'm asking seriously that's a
good question yeah the inevitable I mean
let's get make it even bigger you know
right now the current cosmology the
universe will eventually be destroyed in
some way right entropy will increase and
we will have what's called the heat
death yeah I mean there's plenty of
philosophies that can help you with that
I mean think about stoicism they were
materialists did they think that Wow
okay so my Manor is gonna break down
eventually or the cosmos is gonna break
down [ __ ] it let's not let's not care
about anything no they thought that
there were values that we can live out
here we could endorse we could decide
for in ways that that sometimes sound
kind of existentialist you know so I you
know you can read them and you'll see
them talking about these these sorts of
things the existentialist another great
example you know even the ones who are
very seemingly very gloomy say we can
produce our own value here that we can
recognize within the world which is not
necessarily an absurd world by the way
that's Camus or that Sartre
Simone de Beauvoir calls us an ambiguous
world Gabrielle Marcel says it's a
mysterious world
not every existentialist says it's a
world without meaning there's you know
if you're adopting some sort of theistic
perspective from classical theism the
universe isn't a
you know the current you know universe
isn't all that we've got to work with so
you could endorse something like that as
well nagaru Cornelia
can you tell us the best joke you know
about a philosopher philosophy I don't
know it's the best joke but here's a
good one
why are the disputes and philosophy
departments so incredibly bitter because
the stakes are so low it's uh I've been
telling that joke for twenty years since
I've heard it and I still think it's
very funny but it's kind of laughter
that comes with you know sort of a
recognition of how bad the situation is
Edmundo how important is foreign
language study for philosophical studies
very important if you want to be able to
read your books in different languages
you know in the original gotta study the
language and you can't just study it
enough to like you know be able to read
a newspaper you have to learn you know
the you gotta learn that that whole sort
of linguistic system to some degree and
sometimes it may be of a different time
I mean there's people who are like oh
yeah I'm gonna read Plato so I'm gonna
take some Greek classes well that's
demonic week that's like you know a very
different Greek than Plato's time or
I'll take some biblical Greek well
that's coin a it's not the same thing as
adding Greek so it depends yeah if you
want if you want to be able to read
stuff in the original and if you want to
be exposed to a much wider range of
scholarship then it's good to to read
foreign languages like you know so I do
work on st. Anselm's for example or
Thomas Hobbes or or Alistair McIntyre
right it may be that there's some stuff
out there that I want to read that's in
German or French or even languages that
I can't really read but I can kind of
puzzle through in a way like say
Portuguese or
because the academic stuff is is you
know there's a lot of cognitive grammar
a little bit you can kind of puzzle
things out man it's it's often really
cool to like find there is a French guy
who is talking about this very problem
that I'm talking about and nobody in the
English literature has caught on to it
but this French guy did and being able
to read it you know so it's it's pretty
important Kelly's on Drina Rodriguez
Rodriguez what do I think about romantic
love it seems to be an emotion that
vales rationality should we fight it to
live a better life could you recommend
some books to reflect deeper about it
Thanks I think that romantic love can
sometimes be very irrational especially
when we elevate it as we do often in our
own culture and has been done in Western
culture quite often too you know this is
very high value that trumps other values
but can romantic love be integrated with
rationality I think so and we have
plenty of examples of people who are
able to do that so should we fight
romantic love to live a better life it
depends on depends on what the that
romantic love is like if we're just
talking about some sort of blind
irrational desire like what comes with
you know infatuation I can't stop
talking about this person oh it's so
incredible yeah that's probably gonna
screw you up but you know a deep
intimate love that that comes over time
and is expressed through erotic desire
and actions and and you know sort of a
reciprocity with that I think that's
that's very important in many people's
lives not everybody you know I mean this
is why for example some people might
might choose to be celibate and say I'm
that's a distraction for me but you know
[Music]
yeah
all right Dylan I'm gonna try to get
through as many things as I can very
quickly there's a lot of things here
what I'd like to know what you think
about Marx's relation to Hegel perhaps
Marx more broadly Pinkard thinks marks
got Hegel Ron what's your personal
opinion Marx is the left to galleon that
means that he thinks that Hegel got some
stuff wrong it needs to be improved in
certain ways did Marx fully understand
Hegel maybe maybe not you know
Marx is doing his own thing that's
that's definitely influenced by by Hegel
Oh Kelly's again could you recommend
some philosophers we've written about
migration or emigration well Derrida
started bringing that up back in the 90s
you know it with the figure of the guest
somebody else who I think is
particularly relevant would be own I'm
blanking on his name is Italian
philosopher like my wife actually got to
study with him he writes about Baer life
this happens
I commend Giorgio Agamben you know
Kristeva
also has written some things about
immigration as well so that can be quite
good mike is the vol of the Dark Souls
of philosophy or would that be Hegel I
don't understand the Dark Souls
reference cuz I'm not a gamer so
couldn't couldn't really say all right
Western man if you read as old
Spengler's the decline of the West you
buy into his theory cyclical decline of
all civilizations on their possession of
unique prime symbol reddit when I was
much younger
never bought into it it always seemed a
little bit you know over simplistic to
me oh here's a good question cyrix what
would be the best way to deal with guilt
that arises from empathetic feelings
towards people you see in the world
having a horrible time in this life that
you can only do so much to help as much
turning off this guilt would feel like
being selfish which then brings in more
guilt for you for even thinking about
shutting you off sensitivity to other
people's sufferings this is something I
have strong
so yeah that that is a real conundrum
what you want to do you might actually
like chart it all out and then think
about each of them do you might actually
like chart in all thing for anyone does
it make sense for you to be sort of in
this quandary of helplessness and and
you know guilt or is it better that you
help one person you know and then be
alright with that and that takes a lot
to do
alright we're a little bit close to the
end and I actually do have to end fairly
close to time this time Edmund mundo
have you heard about the Spanish
philosopher Gustavo bueno he developed a
very interesting system called
philosophical materialism
I have not sounds like an interesting
thing and somebody asked about Jordan
Peterson had already answered that let's
see what else I can come to a nice close
on Western man wants to argue about
Trump I don't even bother arguing with
people about Trump anymore you can think
what I feel like everybody's free to
ride their hobbyhorse down the Kings
Highway all right Andre Timo's do you
have any advice for getting into
philosophy of language so we'll close on
this one this is a good good question
I've brought this up before I think that
there that so you know this will serve
who is a linguist not a philosophy of
language but very important linguist
Ferdinand de Saussure recommends that
linguists should make sure that they
know and understand other languages and
as many of them as possible because if
you want to say that you have something
you know to say understand draw upon
from some phenomena you really need to
know that phenomenon I mean anybody
who's a philosopher of language
linguist who only really knows English I
ignore them entirely they have nothing
to tell me so you know you want to study
languages for the sake of understanding
those languages and then you can start
you know generalizing about about you
know philosophy of language the other
thing I would say is there's a lot of
great philosophy of language in ancient
and medieval philosophy you don't want
to ignore any of that sort of stuff then
you know you know you think about what
happens in the modern period and with
you know German romanticists and and
their discussions of language that's
important and then we get you know
continental and analytic philosophy and
you want a study as broadly across as
you can so like I mentioned your you're
not ignoring key figures and reinventing
wheels that don't need to be reinvented
or ignoring insights that other people
have left out so all right so I'm going
to bring us to a close thanks for all of
the comments and questions I didn't get
to a few of them at the end but try to
get to as much as we can
I've got to take care of some editorial
work now before I have a few other
obligations to get to so we do this
every month again it's it's underwritten
by my patreon supporters so let's say
thanks to them as well and we'll do this
again next month we do our philosophy
pop up will be doing another philosophy
pop up later this month on Facebook live
and I think that's pretty much it on my
end
all right have a great afternoon for for
those of you here in this hemisphere
those are you in other places great
morning great evening great great night